And we're going to excuse Mayor Gray and Ben
Reeves, our city manager, because they are in New York
right now attending to some city business to help us with some things that
we're working on. We're going to move into the Pledge of Allegiance, and I will
lead you in that. Please join me for the Pledge of Allegiance.
I pledge allegiance to the flag of the United States
of America and to the republic for which it stands. I pledge
allegiance to the flag of the United States of America, and to the republic for
which it stands, one nation under God, indivisible, with liberty and
justice for all.
Okay, so this afternoon's meeting is going to
be short and sweet. It was something that we needed to call a special meeting
for because of some timelines and deadlines.
So we will be looking at a resolution of Eagle
Mountain City, Utah, protesting The Red Cedar Corporation annexation
petition filed with the Town of Cedar Fort on July 27th,
2026. And I'll invite Marcus to present
the item. Yes, so we became aware of this,
I believe yesterday, that the petition for annexation
was filed under state code. Prior to even
filing the petition, the petitioner should have sent a notice of
intent to file a petition with us. Because we are an affected entity,
and that is one of the procedural problems with their petition.
So we drafted a protest letter because this overlaps
with our annexation policy plan expansion area, and and we have
some interest in potentially annexing a portion of that proposed
annexation into Eagle Mountain City. Additionally, we've had contact
with. the representatives of several of the landowners that
are proposed to be annexed into Cedar Fort, and they do not desire to be
annexed into Cedar Fort and are very
troubled by this petition. So we are filing as an affected
entity. We have standing to file a protest, and that's what this would be,
a resolution to do that. Thank you.
Just— and I'd like to recognize that Mayor Gray and
Ben Reeves are both online, but because they're remote,
I'll continue to conduct the meeting unless the mayor tells me otherwise.
Um, does council have any questions about the item that
is at hand?
This is Craig. I have no questions. Okay.
Council Member Hewish, do you have any questions?
I think, uh, this, this is just a procedural step
in a protest. What, what is the next step after the protest
is filed? Yeah, so we'll file the protest with the Utah County
Clerk, after which the Boundary
Commission would have to set a date for a public hearing, and we would have
the opportunity to present at that hearing. And then they would make a decision on
how to recommend, you know, what Cedar Fort does.
My reading of the laws is not actually binding on the town of Cedar Fort,
but it would certainly bear a lot of persuasive
weight. We would have, if they went forth with the annexation, then we
would have to look at other legal recourse if they chose not to follow the
Boundary Commission's recommendation. Okay.
Councilmember Wood, do you have anything that you'd like to share? Nope.
All right. So with that, if no one else has any other items—
oh, okay. Steve. Just, uh, Marcus can
clarify for me, but it appears unless Cedar Fort changes
their mind, on September 15th they will still have a public hearing on this.
They can't move forward with the public hearing while there's a pending
protest. Okay, what I read in state code was that they
can have the public hearing, they can deny the application, but they can't approve it.
Yes, I mean, that's a little bit more, I guess, precise.
Yes, they could deny the annexation petition without
waiting for the protest to play out, and that would moot the protest, but they
can't approve it until the protest plays out.
Marcus, maybe I have one question. How is it that they can,
Force a landowner to be part of an annexation application against
their will? That is one of the problems with the petition.
Under state law, you need to have landowners covering at least
50% of the total area within the annexation, proposed annexation area,
that signed the petition. And my understanding is that did not occur here,
that it was only the Red Cedar Corporation who was the petitioner.
They're the only ones that signed it, and they own approximately a third of the
land area, and none of the other landowners, most of which are associated with the
Holbrooks, And they none of them
signed it. It's my is my understanding, and so that
is one of the procedural problems is that it's the petition's invalid because it doesn't
have the adequate signatures. That being said, my reading
of state law is if you do meet the requirements and have
50% of the landowners sign,
say the landowner is covering 50% of the total area, and that covers one
third of the total value. If you meet both those requirements and a
couple other minor procedural requirements, you could force other
landowners into an annexation into a municipality that they don't want to be annexed into.
So that is something that is allowable under state law, but not under these circumstances.
Is the reason that they're being included in this is because their property lies
between the applicant and the city that
they want to annex to? So in this area, there is a,
I guess, a corridor, if you will, of parcels that
are between Cedar Fort and Eagle Mountain and within unincorporated Utah
County. The Red Cedar Corporation parcels are actually just to the north of this corridor.
And all the ones to the south are, again, most of them are
associated with the Holbrook family. And I
can't, I mean, I have ideas, but I don't know what their motives are for
including them. Thank you. Okay, no further questions.
Thank you. Does, does anyone else on council have any more questions or any more
comments from those that are present? All right, so then I'll call for
a motion. Mayor Pro Tempore, I'll make a motion.
I move that the city council adopt a resolution of Eagle Mountain City,
Utah, protesting the Red Cedar Corporation annexation petition
filed with the town of Cedar Fort on July 27th,
2026. Second. All right, we have a motion from
Council Member Wood and a second from Council Member Wright. Let's begin
the vote with me. Yes. Council Member?
Yes. Council Member Whiting?
Yes. Council Member Wood?
Yes. Council Member Hewish? Yes. Good job,
you guys. I had a real hard time because we don't have our name plaques
up. Thank you all
for that. I'll call for a motion to adjourn. You need to
announce that it's been, uh, what the vote was.
Um, the, the vote, uh, was 5 to 0, passes.
Will you entertain a motion, Mayor Pro Tem? I sure will. Motion to adjourn.
Oh, second. We have a motion from Council Member
Wood and a motion, a second from Council Member Wright. All in favor, please say
aye. Aye. Aye. All right, we're adjourned at
5:23 PM. Thank you.